[Musique]
monsieur le président il ya une question
que j'ai envie de vous poser depuis bien
longtemps
est ce qu'il est possible quand on
occupe des fonctions de garder le
contact avec les français de savoir
qu'ils sont de savoir ce qu'ils pensent
et ils de percevoir vraiment ce qu'ils
attendent de leur président je pense que
c'est possible
de toute façon c'est un problème qui
serait le même pour tout président
d'abord on dispose de beaucoup
d'informations
les mêmes d'informations que tous les
français puisque le matin au réveil on
écoute la radio on lit les journaux je
regarde la télévision générale à à
l'heure du déjeuner et je reçois donc
les mêmes informations que les français
ensuite rien à cacher non je ne crois
pas qu'on puisse cacher quoi que ce soit
dans un monde où il ya tellement
d'informations
d'autre part y'a des jours sa formation
plus directe par exemple je reçois un
courrier j'ai reçu pendant mon septennat
1 million 400 mille lettres de
françaises et de français et jean-louis
d'abord naturellement un grand nombre et
ensuite tous les mois j'ai une analyse
de ces lettres pour montrer les types de
préoccupations de mes correspondants
plan fait il ya une vie de famille
j'ai quatre enfants qui ont la vie et
celle de leurs enfants sont deux
adolescents afin qu'ils ont fait leurs
études pendant cette période quand tu es
dans les établissements d'enseignement
qu'en france avis militaire ainsi de
suite donc qui apporte aussi le les
échos de la vie quotidienne de france
oui peut-être mais enfin fait que la
plupart du temps on apprend beaucoup de
choses chez les plissés ou en allant
acheter un paquet de cigarettes au tabac
du coin je voulais dire je n'y allais
pas tout de même fait pas qu'est ce que
le public car je te veux dire par
exemple dimanche dernier nous rentrions
à la campagne nous avons eu une panne de
une peine d'auto une peine 2 des voyages
alors ça va aller en roue libre
heureusement jusqu'au prochain garage à
les faire réparer dans la voiture au
garage et dans la vie d'un courant jet
même beaucoup d'occasions de rencontres
avec les françaises et les français dès
le matin souvent sur les promenades
autour d'élise et j'envoie et il est de
dire bonjour nous parlons des changes
ont quelques réflexions et enfin une
chose c'est que je suis quelqu'un qui
regarde beaucoup il ya eu une
information par le regard quand vous
circulez dans la ville quand vous
regardez les visages des saints des jo
vous participez à des réunions et moi
c'est par le regard que j'observe ou
alors j'imagine que vous tenez compte
est ce que vous êtes cernés j'essaie
d'en tenir compte
aurait été votre question est plutôt
j'imagine de dire n'est ce pas est ce
que on peut sentir
on sait est-ce qu'on peut sentir à cause
de la ville très particulière qu'on mène
sur cette ville dirais ceci pour le mon
prochain septennat si je suis élu je
crois que faut distinguer tout à fait
deux choses il ya la vie officielle
l'avis officiel la président république
française elle doit être marquée par la
dignité parce que nous sommes qu'en pays
un ancien pays
et puis il ya la vie personnelle elle
doit être aussi simple que possible mais
je vais forcer je m'efforcerai davantage
encore alors vous êtes salle écoute des
femmes bien sûr vous avez fait de la
condition féminine
une des priorités à votre arrivée à
l'elysée est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que tout est à peu près
effet en ce qui concerne la condition
féminine ou risques vous pourriez faire
encore plus de choses on doit faire plus
froid que l'idée le message est passé
c'est à dire que les femmes françaises
doivent avoir une place importante dans
la société française croit que ce
message est passé il ya encore quelques
années il était contestée où on lui
disait du bout des lèvres
donc le message est passé je crois
également qu'un certain nombre de choses
importantes ont été entreprises
concernant la condition féminine donc il
ya eu des progrès mais je crois qu'il ya
davantage encore à faire sur le point
suivant
au début comme il s'agissait de quelque
chose de nouveau qui était cet exercice
des responsabilités par les femmes on a
peut-être trois mille accents justement
sur ce seul aspect exercice des
responsabilités vie professionnelle des
femmes et je souhaite maintenant qu'on
mette un peu plus l'accent sur le
problème de la compatibilité entre la
vie professionnelle des femmes et la vie
de famille comment les femmes
peuvent-elles à la fois avoir une vie
professionnelle à laquelle elle aspire
et à mon avis tout aspirant à voir une
certaine vie profane et la ville sammy
alors deux idées là-dessus
d'une part le développement du travail à
temps partiel qui doit pas être une
règle mais qui est une possibilité
et pour lequel savez j'ai prévu un grand
développement travaillent à temps
partiel qui doit s'accompagner d'une
carrière
nationalement et puis également le
problème de l'éducation des très jeunes
enfants
c'est à dire avant la maternelle c'était
le magret
d'élever son enfant pendant quelques
moments je crois je pense que c'est le
désir profond de beaucoup de femmes
entrent dans que des enfants jusqu'à
deux ou trois ans avant l'arrivée
alors là il ya probablement des formules
d'abord d'organisation qu'on peut
trouver et plus aussi un problème de
ressources et je crois que nous devons
créer un type de ressource pour les
jeunes femmes qui pendant cette période
choisie c'est d'élever leurs enfants
pourrait presque appeler ça un salaire
voilà le mot ne ferait pas c'est une
ressource mais en face il blessé sept
îles et enfin si mais pour le fn
français vous avez une chose si vous me
permettez va j'ai un secret avec les
femmes françaises c'est à dire que si
j'ai attaché tellement d'importance pour
une raison profonde et tout secret de le
dire un peu plus tôt aujourd'hui sur
l'eau oui alors vous avez vous avez
cherché aussi à réduire les inégalités
naturellement on a vu ça en ce qui
concerne les personnes âgées c'est très
important mais je voudrais moi vous dire
une chose il ya une catégorie de
français qui sent un peu mal aimé je
vais vous dire qu'ils se sont ce qu'on
appelle les français moyens mais c'est
pas péjoratif du tout un moyen je dire
ce sont les emplois de bureau voyez les
gens qui vont au bureau tous les matins
tous les après midi qu'ils rentrent chez
eux 18 heures le soir et tout ça qui ont
pas une vie très drôle qui gagne pas
très mal leur vie mais juste un tout
petit peu au dessus du plafond et qui
donc ne peuvent pas bénéficier de
certaines prestations sociales qui sont
bien utiles aux autres qu'il faut que
les autres continuent à voir mais ils ne
peuvent pas les avoir un risque il n'y
aurait pas quelque chose à faire pour
cela est ce que vous me reposer une
question chez les personnes âgées
si vous voulez mincir parlons d'abord de
ces îles ont ce sentiment
oui mon sentiment pourquoi d'abord parce
que c'est une catégorie qui est la plus
nombreuse
actuellement des français au travail ce
même maintenant plus l'ombre légèrement
plus nombreux que les ouvriers et ils
voient que dans les grands débats
sociaux on s'occupe moins deux que d
autrui
pourquoi c'est arrivé parce commission
dans une situation moyenne et qu' il
fallait corriger les grandes injustices
et grant a dû un but six étaient tous
debout qui se sont dit on ne s'occupe
pas de nous et d'autre part pour
corriger certaines de ces grandes
injustices et notamment tout ce qui
était les basses rémunérations
on a créé des avantages sociaux pour les
catégories qui avaient déplu petite
rémunération qui
ne sont pas appliquées ou un
parfaitement appliqué à cette catégorie
moyenne par exemple un certain type de
logement certaines prestations même
familial ont des plafonds qu'ils font
qui n'en bénéficient pas et ils ont
gentiment donc d'être mal quelquefois le
plafond est et ce qu'il gagne c'est tout
et comme différent fin dangereux je
voulais je crois je lui en ai parlé
l'autre jour je préparais à lille en
effet cette catégorie très importante et
ça devient de plus en plus la partie
centrale de la france alors je pense que
ce que nous devons faire c'est ceci est
il fallait faire l'effort pour les
catégories les plus défavorisées
il fallait le faire mais ayant consacré
des ressources à cet effort il faut
maintenant voir si ce qui a été fait
pour les catégories moyennes et pas dans
une certaine mesure trop peu injuste
dont quatre au p 3 et regardez au point
de vue précisément de de l'aide au
logement à l'accession à la propriété
tous les questions de plafonds de
ressources si nous ne devons pas revoir
ces plafonds de ressources
éventuellement supprimer certains
d'entre eux une autre question
importante
c'est je suis partisan pour ces
catégories du maintien de ce qu'on
appelle le quotient familial dans la
peau il y à des candidats je mets ça qui
propose la suppression du quotient
familial
je suis contre cette suppression parce
que ce serait la même chose on
commencerait par mettre un plafond qui
serait assez haut naturellement on
dirait aux catégories moyennes ça ne
vous concerne pas et puis avec
l'évolution la hausse des prix ainsi de
suite les catégories moyennes seraient
atteintes
donc voyez ce que je veux dire réviser
les plafonds de ressources pour leur
donner accès à certaines facilités ou à
certaines prestations maintien du
quotient familial
les personnes âgées vous avez fait pour
tous pour elle n'est pas encore bien sûr
l'idéal étant donné que l'idéal pourrait
être quelque chose de bien plus
important
ce que je sais c'est que ces personnes
âgées souvent ont des problèmes parce
qu'elles ont des petites économies
qu'elle placé des petites économies ça
rapporte pas grand-chose et quelquefois
fin c'est tout sous 2 du taux
d'inflation et les personnages et
c'était un des grands efforts pas
personnel c'est moi qui ai notamment
conduit tout seul c'était fort c'était
un effort national en pendant sept ans
la progression du niveau de vie des
personnes âgées qui était à la
correction d'une grande injustice a
représenté une dépense supplémentaire
par rapport à la simple
poursuite de ce qu'on faisait avant de
50 milliards de francs que les français
ont donc apporté sa vie a été normal
alors d'abord cet effort sera poursuivi
elles se disent on a parlé de nous dans
le passé on parle maintenant de la
jeunesse est ce qu on va l'oublier on va
naturellement poursuivre l'effort c'est
à dire la progression du pouvoir d'achat
les personnes âgées et notamment du
minimum vieillesse
deuxième sujet je crois que nous
lancerons d'inspiration c'est de rester
chez elle c'est le problème du maintien
domicile alors il ya beaucoup de
questions à cet égard aux aménagements
du logement aides à domicile et mon
objectif c'est qu'ils viennent 50 %
d'heures de plus des domiciles dans le
prochain septennat pour permettre le
maintien chez elles les personnes âgées
qui le souhaitent
vous avez parlé de la question de l'
épargne à regarder à l'heure actuelle le
dernier emprunt d'état les emprunts
d'état ont les se sait que vous allez
partout dans tous les établissements on
l'a placé à un taux d'intérêt de 13,8
pour cent taux d'intérêt et la hausse
des prix à l'heure actuelle est encore
trop forte
bien sûr elle est comme vous avez vu un
peu supérieure à 12% et nous espérons
d'ailleurs on réduire le taux d'ici la
fin de l'année donc en par exemple en
souscrivant un emprunt on était protégé
contre le feu en fait il fallait
conseiller
il faut les conseillers il faut aussi je
vous dis je le sais j'en prends
l'engagement que toutes les émissions
tous les empreintes qui sont faits
auprès du grand public est un taux
d'intérêt qui soit supérieur au tournant
vous avez parlé notamment des jeunes
bien sûr on va y revenir aux jeunes mais
je voulais parler d'abord de la famille
on a un peu l'impression que les valeurs
familiales se perdent tout le monde son
plein autour de nous alors est ce que
vous croyez qu'il ressorte il est du
ressort du chef de l'état d' essayer de
redonner une espèce d'élan en cette
matière et puis et puis aussi en ce qui
concerne la démographie on se plaint
qu'il y a de moins en moins d'enfants
mais c'est difficile matériellement
élever des enfants
matériellement et moralement la famille
s'est pas l'état et les pays dans lequel
la famille c'est l'état s'était et la
mort de la famille dont la famille est
la cellule de base de la société
française les 10
plusieurs reprises j'ai la chance de
vivre dans une famille heureuse c'est
une grande chance parce que vous aussi
d'ailleurs
et quand on a cette chance on se rend
compte que ses supérieurs tout autre
chose dans la vie donc la famille boîte
est la cellule de base de la société
française elle a des problèmes matériels
on a cherché à les améliorer au cours
des dernières années et vous savez que
alors qu'avant dans la période de
prospérité il n'y avait pas de
progression pouvoir d'achat des familles
depuis 1974 deuxième effort de
solidarité il a eu un effort d une
progression de thouars d'achat des
familles ceux ci doivent poursuivre avec
un accent particulier pour les familles
de trois enfants et plus est également
il faut dire pour les femmes qui élèvent
de très jeunes enfants c'est les deux
situations qui sont économiquement
difficile parce que à partir de 3
enfants on voit bien que la charge que
la dépense pour la famille et tous
croient tout de même beaucoup plus
rapidement et quant à la natalité vous
avez vu parce que c'est un signe de
vitalité français qu'en 1980 la natalité
à romain clean mais cela n'est pas
encore suffisant tout ça mais la
remontée
et comme on n'arrive pas à trouver des
explications détaillées de ce genre de
phénomène ça exprime en quelque sorte la
vitalité d'une société et ça prouve
qu'en 1981 la france a retrouvé
confiance en elle meetic mois ces jeunes
qui vont grandir chatte inquiète
pourrait parce que ce que je vois ce que
je connais ce que je fréquente et j'en
vois beaucoup j'ai l'impression qu'ils
sont coincés qu'ils ont peur du chômage
c'est un mot qui revient toujours dans
leurs conversations sont hors de l'échec
très difficile les études et puis ils
ont peur de la guerre comme l'étions
jeune moi c'était bien avant on avait
peur de la guerre et au fond c'était la
chose dont on avait peur
le problème de l'emploi ne se posait pas
dans les mêmes conditions vous souvenir
discuter en direct pour faire comme
métier les uns les autres
la question est de savoir si on aurait
la capacité d'accéder à ce métier nous
dire sur les accès non laurent alors à
l'heure actuelle et bien en corse et de
craintes il ya d'abord la crainte de la
guerre et je veux que la france reste un
pays qui lutte pour la paix que ça soit
un pays formé pacifique et je souhaite
la jeunesse française des buteurs dans
mes réunions combien l'applaudissait ce
thème que nous restons un pays qui se
bat pour la paix
pour la question de l'emploi je vais
présenter un certain nombre de
propositions vous avez vues détaillées
avec l'idée suivante faire en sorte que
d'ici 1985
tout jeune française est tout jeune
français qui arrivent en âge de travail
et se voit offrir soit un poste de
travail donc soit un emploi soit la
poursuite de sa formation
parce que je souhaite que les jeunes
français et accède au travail avec un
niveau de formation élevé
donc il y à cette préoccupation de
l'emploi seront actionnés par la seule
préoccupation de la jeunesse c'est le
temps qu'on aurait tort de croire
qu'elle accélère elle veut aussi je
dirais avoir un rôle faire quelque chose
que sa vie est un sens et c'est pourquoi
dans je m'efforce de deux de faire
apparaître que la france est un pays qui
veut avoir une vocation qui doit faire
quelque chose dans le comment faire
passer ce message là le message passe je
suis très frappé par exemple vous et du
soutien que je dresse apporter ma
campagne et je suis très frappé de voir
que des thèmes comme par exemple le
tiers-monde
le fait que la france soit un pays
généreux qui agissent dans le monde 26
replier son égoïsme
c'est un thème que je soutiens tout à
fait la jeunesse je veux que la france
la jeunesse française connaissent le
monde pour ça qu'elle parcourt le monde
autant que possible et je veux qu'elle
apparaisse comme jeunesse qui apportent
quelque chose donc vous voyez d'une part
président le problème de l'emploi et
d'autre part que des jeunes aient le
sentiment que leur vie à cette façon le
jury sera tranquille sur le problème de
l'emploi leur vie aura un sens que ce
n'est pas uniquement il faut non on peut
très bien avoir des sortes de sociétés à
souligner non il faut une société
vivante qui s'intéressent au problème du
groupe
cependant grandes transformations
auxquelles la france peut apporter
quelque chose
enfin une dernière question j'aimerais
que vous m'expliquer en détail ce que
vous avez voulu dire dans l'une de vos
dix propositions pas d'ailleurs c'était
la 10e lorsque vous disiez la france
propre
les français par dans les français
propriétaires de la france moi j'adore
le mot propriétaire trouve sa
confortable mais le propriétaire de la
france eh bien je sais meme je dis ceci
jeudi les français propriétaires
individuels de la france parce qu'il ya
une forme propriété la france qu'on
pourrait imaginer qu'ils seraient la
propriété collective ou et tactiques de
la france
vous voyez qu'à l'heure actuelle y un
rejet par les français les structures
étatiques ou trempe étatiques et donc ce
que je voudrais c'est que les français
et les françaises pour propriétaires
individuels de là
vous en avez déjà beaucoup vous avez par
exemple dans l'agriculture un grand
nombre d'agriculteurs qui possèdent de
leur exploitation leur outil de travail
vous avez parmi les professions
libérales famille les commerçants les
artisans
beaucoup de travailleurs qui supporters
des risques importants et qui sont
propriétaires de leur activité
économique de l'an fonds de commerce
mais ce doit être une règle générale en
france que chaque français et chaque
français se disent je possède un bout de
la france c'est très français d'ailleurs
comme sentiment je crois parce que nous
se répéter rien d'origine ou un pays
rural n'est pas nous avons le sens de la
propriété deux cas deux exemples premier
exemple le l'actionnariat dans les
entreprises il est pour moi tout à fait
si vous voulez choquant que quelqu'un
qui travaille toute sa vie dans une
entreprise dans possèdent leur rien vous
avez vu ce qui a été fait il a eu d'une
part ce qu'on a fait la loi monory pour
faciliter des achats d'actions francs
que ça concerne est largement plus d'un
million de personnes on a dû passer aux
alentours de 2 millions de personnes
il a eu la loi que j'ai proposé au
parlement qui l'a adoptée pour la
distribution d'actions aux salariés des
entreprises
distribution gratuite et j'ai eu des
résultats ce matin il y aura un million
cent mille bénéficiaires individuels
donc ça fait les familles en réalité qui
vont recevoir de ses actions ils
recevront chacun en moyenne aux environs
de 2400 francs d'actions de leur
entreprise ce n'est pas considérable
ils deviennent propriétaires autre
exemple le logement pour appeler contre
franck rousseau des grands ensembles
car mon arrivait l'elysée j'ai demandé
qu'on arrête cela et que l'on se tourne
vers la maison individuelle on a
construit en sept ans un million huit
cent quarante mille maisons
individuelles et je souhaite que la
proportion s'accroissent et pour
faciliter l'acquisition de ces maisons
j'ai proposé vous avez dû voir cela
aussi ce que j'ai appelé un plan
d'épargné propriétaires à 20 plans
d'épargne-logement je souhaite un plan
dépend de propriété c'est-à-dire que les
gens puissent acquérir leur logement et
notamment leur premier logement en
particulier les jeunes qu'aux logements
soit 9 s'il veulent construire où que ce
soit déjà un logement existant s'ils
veulent améliorer ou utiliser un
logement existant pour que voit pas de
chaque français et chaque français se
disent j'ai les droits politiques en
france le citoyen libre d'hier on le
voit bien dans la campagne
une en lavant campagne mais qu'ils se
disent aussi je participe la vie de la
france je possède mon morceau de la
france donc c'est ça que j'ai voulu dire
les français propriétaires individuels
de la france aujourd'hui nous avons
parlé ensemble
1 p sont de la vie quotidienne des
français et demain je parlerai de la
place et du rôle de la france dans le
monde de la grandeur de la france avec
un historien arthur conte et je vous
remercie d'avoir bien voulu me poser vos
questions
[Musique]